bonjour à tous et à tous Je me présente
à vous en tant que amine Diwan artiste
violoniste compositeur j'ai suivi un
parcours assez classique j'ai fait une
quinzaine d'années au Conservatoire la
base j'ai appris le chant le solfège et
j'ai fait de l'orchestre ce qui est
incroyable c'est qu'elle orchestre on
apprend à jouer on apprend à écouter
jouer et enfin le truc le plus important
et le plus difficile on apprend à
écouter les autres jouets on s'en rend
pas compte mais c'est toute une
discipline d'arriver à se concentrer sur
ce que l'on joue et d'écouter ce que la
personne à côté fait réussir à se
coordonner si on est en avance si elle
est en retard pour avoir un rendu
agréable à l'oreille
j'ai jamais rêvé d'être violoniste
professionnel j'ai toujours voulu garder
ça comme une passion comme un exutoire
comme un moment d'évasion parce qu'on
nous fait très vite comprendre qu'on est
jeune que la musique
il y aura beaucoup de gens toujours plus
fort que nous à moins d'être un acharné
de travailler 10 heures par jour d'avoir
un talent
c'est très difficile de pouvoir y vivre
et jamais de la vie en fait j'aurais
imaginer que ça serait une vidéo de
mwaka Moon de Kalash et damso reprise au
violon dans la cage d'escalier d'un ami
à moi tourner le soir du nouvel an qui
me rendrait violoniste célèbre de là ça
m'a suivi de nombreuses collaborations
j'ai travaillé avec de nombreux artistes
allant de la variété jusqu'au rap en
passant par la pop et j'ai pu développer
mon oreille mon écoute et ma musicalité
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
l'influence qu'à la musique sur le
cerveau
et de comment elle peut tromper nos sens
et nous faire voyager
je vous rassure je n'ai aucune notion
neurologie ni même en médecine mais
l'histoire que je vais vous raconter
s'appuie sur des expériences que j'ai
vécu et sur la manière dont je conçois
la musique et sur comment elle peut
tromper notre cerveau
avant toute chose j'aimerais définir de
terme le terme d'émotion et le terme de
sentiment une émotion c'est quelque
chose de très intense qui nous submerge
qui a tendance à nous faire perdre nos
moyens
tant elle est éphémère étant altant elle
disparaître alors que le sentiment lui
c'est simplement la prise de conscience
de cet état émotionnel
quand parle de voyage on pense souvent
moi la première chose qui me vient c'est
le voyage physique c'est le fait de
partir d'un point A pour aller à un
point B je n'avais jamais beaucoup
voyagé par le passé et il y a deux ans
j'étais déjà compositeur et je m'étais
retrouvé face à un mur je n'arrivais pas
à composer j'étais un peu comme
l'artiste comme l'écrivain qui se
retrouve face à la face à la feuille
blanche
et j'avais besoin de trouver
l'inspiration du coup ma conseillé en
Belgique parce qu'en Belgique on vend
souvent la couleur musicale les artistes
belges
l'énergie des compositeurs belges et je
me suis dit pourquoi pas organiser un
petit voyage où je vais faire matin midi
soir musique finalement j'y suis allé
j'ai rencontré des artistes et des
compositeurs incroyables
mais malheureusement je ne travaillais
qu'une seule soirée j'ai fait de la
musique qu'une seule soirée et tout le
reste en fait on a fait la fête ensemble
j'ai appris à les connaître et ils m'ont
confié en fait leurs inspirations
comment il concevait la musique
qu'est-ce qu'il leur donnait envie de
faire de la musique j'écoutais leurs
histoires leurs anecdotes et du coup je
suis en train à Paris à peine arrive à
Paris coïncidence incroyable ça faisait
des semaines qu'on avait pas contacté
pour aller en studio et j'étais un peu
au point mort j'avais limite plus trop
envie de faire de la musique je voulais
faire une petite pause et là on
m'appelle on me dit oui amine on a
besoin de toi on a envie que tu ramènes
ton violon et que tu arrives à pousser
l'émotion du morceau de notre artiste au
maximum que tu sublimes le morceau mais
la seule condition la seule contrainte
c'est que là on a la fin de la journée
il nous reste plus qu'une heure tu as
une heure pour faire tout ça du coup moi
forcément j'y vais je pensais pas
forcément être l'homme de la situation
mais je me suis je vais y aller je vais
tenter je vais voir ce qui en sort et
j'avais pas du tout à ce moment là le
ressenti que ce voyage
m'avait permis de passer un cap dans ma
musique au contraire j'avais juste passé
un bon moment c'est tout mais j'avais
pas progressé musicalement et là en fait
j'arrive j'enregistre ma musique
j'arrive directement bizarrement à
capter l'énergie et l'émotion de
l'artiste ce qui voulait transmettre et
là en une demi-heure en fait j'avais
tout enregistré tout était bouclé et là
l'artiste j'aimerais me dire merci mais
je sais pas comment tu as fait mais tu
as réussi vraiment à comprendre à mettre
des notes là où moi je n'arrivais pas à
mettre des mots et là j'ai un déclic
dans ma tête je me suis ok cette
barrière mentale que je m'étais fixée
que je m'étais mise je ne sais pas
comment avait disparu par le simple fait
de d'avoir voyagé d'avoir écouté et de
mettre inspiré en fait de l'énergie et
des couleurs musicales d'autres
compositeurs maintenant quand on parle
de voyage et surtout de voyage musical
moi je pense aussi au voyage
métaphysique
ça va être ce voyage comme lorsqu'on lit
un livre c'est le voyage où notre corps
reste mais notre cerveau voyage notre
cerveau est transporté ailleurs je pense
aussi au dessin moi ça a été très vite
par le dessin que j'ai découvert lorsque
j'étais jeune chez ce genre d'élèves qui
m'ennuie très vite en cours les journées
étaient très très longues et le seul
échappatoire le Salix histoires que j'ai
trouvé c'était le dessin c'est à dire
une fois arrivé en cours je le dessiner
et là les journées passaient extrêmement
vite je ne voyais plus les journées
passées et pourtant j'ai dessiné
beaucoup en fait avec du recul je me
suis rendu compte que tout ce que je
dessinais c'était des choses en action
des choses en mouvement j'étais un grand
fan de One Piece et je le suis toujours
et je dessinais que des scènes qui
bougeaient et je me suis rendu compte en
fait que avec la musique c'est pareil
quand je vous dis de fermer les yeux et
d'écouter par exemple une musique qui
vient du Brésil qui soit de la fun
brésilienne qui soit de la musique
asiatique vient de la musique Chaabi
d'Algérie tout de suite en fait c'est
première note ses premiers rythmes nous
transporte à l'autre bout du monde et ça
je trouve ça fou j'ai envie de vous
faire une petite démonstration je vais
vous demander de fermer les yeux vous
concentrer et de regarder de me laisser
d'imaginer qu'est-ce que la musique vous
évoque je vais simplement allumer le
micro avant
c'est une musique qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur
[Musique]
vous avez reconnu
[Applaudissements]
on a ce pouvoir on a ce pouvoir sur nos
auditeurs sur les gens qui nous écoutent
de contrôler les émotions de contrôler
ce voyage de décider si on veut faire
ressentir quelque chose de triste
quelque chose de joyeux c'est vous de se
dire que le simple fait d'estomper
certains de nos sens et dans prioriser
d'autres comme l'écoute peut en fait
nous faire voyager à l'autre bout du
monde en quelques secondes en tant
compositeur on a certaines techniques
assez classique d'autres un peu plus
complexes qui nous permettent en fait de
décider quelle émotion souhaite
transmettre on a un exemple tout simple
ça va être les gammes certaines gammes
comme les gammes majeures vont nous
faire ressentir quelque chose d'assez
joyeux en utilisant une gamme ou des
accords mineurs on peut faire ressentir
de la tristesse après ça peut être
quelque chose encore plus simple on sait
qu'il y a certains rythmes qui nous font
plus danser que d'autres et certains
instruments comme Candy par exemple
faire pleurer les violons on sait que le
violon est très
est très apte à faire ressentir quelque
chose de plus mélancolique là où la
guitare est beaucoup plus festive j'ai
envie de vous faire cette démonstration
avec les gammes je vais vous jouer une
gamme majeure la gamme de Do majeur
pour vous montrer
ça vous apporte un peu de joie et
ensuite je vous montrerai l'inverse avec
la gamme mineure ici je voulais quelque
chose de majeur
[Musique]
c'est assez joyeux et maintenant on va
faire l'inverse on va aller sur quelque
chose de mineur en restant dans la gamme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'il faut en fait ce qu'on peut
passer de quelque chose d'assez triste
assez joyeux en fait c'est vraiment les
premières notes qui nous viennent et
souvent en fait en tant compositeur on
va essayer de capter en fait cette note
ce moment pour le pousser à l'intense
ce qui est beau dans l'improvisation
c'est quel temps à faire ressortir ce
côté assez léger de la musique
c'est
ça me fait penser à ce moment ce moment
où on écoute une musique ou la musique
nous rappelle un souvenir fort me fait
penser à quelqu'un ne fait penser à un
endroit et on n'a pas d'explication on
sait pas pourquoi
et bien c'est comme lorsqu'on revient
d'un voyage on ne sait pas ce que le
voyage nous a appris on l'apprend
seulement une fois le voyage fini
lorsqu'on se retourne et qu'on fait le
bilan ben j'aimerais revenir sur ces
deux termes d'émotion et de sentiments
on disait que l'émotion c'était quelque
chose de très très intense très fort
mais qui était assez court assez
éphémère l'émotion dure maximum 90
secondes là où le sentiment lui
comme je disais c'était la prise de
conscience de cet émotionnel lui Dieu
entre 90 secondes et 70 ans en fait
c'est au moment où le voyage musical se
finit se termine qu'on décide de garder
de lier en fait ses souvenirs ces
mélodies à cette nostalgie
et de conserver ces moments finalement
ce n'est qu'une fois le voyage fini la
musique finit qu'on se rend compte de
l'intensité du moment
ce n'est qu'une fois arrivé au bout du
voyage qu'on
se rend compte qu'on a des musiques qui
nous resteront à vie ou pas
et une fois que j'ai fini
[Musique]
on se rend compte en fait que la musique
tient toute son intensité non pas
forcément de la théorie musicale mais de
cette légèreté cette légèreté en fait on
se laisse porter comme une vague par la
musique
je vous avoue que ce soir je n'aurais
jamais imaginé un jour me retrouver ici
devant vous animer une conférence tête
et pourtant je suis ici et vous aussi la
seule raison qui me vient c'est que j'ai
laissé la musique distraire mon cerveau
et le convaincre que mes histoires et
mes mélodies allaient vous intéresser et
vous apporter quelque chose j'espère que
cette conférence vous aura plu je vous
remercie pour votre attention je tenais
à remercier merci
[Applaudissements]
merci je tenais enfin sur toi merci
l'équipe TEDx pour m'avoir invité
accompagné la préparation de mon
discours et tous ceux qui me soutiennent
mes proches et tout particulièrement ma
soeur sans qui je n'aurais jamais réussi
à accomplir toutes ces belles choses
merci
[Applaudissements]